el salvador última detalles para
comenzar con el uso del beat con como
moneda de curso legal en ese país
centroamericano los detalles de esta
noticia destacada los tiene daniela
blandón de economía de la redacción de
france 24 daniela los detalles porque ya
la ley empieza a partir del martes si
señor santiago como ésta pues mire en
medio del escepticismo y la
incertidumbre de este pequeño país es
centroamericano se convertirá en el
primero del mundo en darle curso legal a
esta cripto moneda para hacerle compañía
al dólar que es su divisa oficial desde
hace 20 años nuestro corresponsal
vladimir chamorro nos amplía la
información
el zonte es una pequeña comunidad
costera famosa por la fuerza de sus olas
pero en 2019 la oleada del beat coin
cambiaría para siempre el destino de
esta concurrida playa somos los primeros
en el país que empezó bitcoin somos
quienes sembramos la semilla ahora el
mundo entero tiene sus ojos sobre el
salvador
esa semilla nació por un donante anónimo
quien decidió patrocinar con bitcoins
los proyectos sociales que jorge lidera
desde casa esperanza la ola se extendió
y 200 atm dedicados a la cripta divisa
han sido instalados en todo el país el
gobierno ha ofrecido el equivalente a 30
dólares en bitcoin a quienes descarguen
el archivo ballet la billetera
electrónica oficial en su celular pero
el incentivo no ha sido suficiente para
romper la apatía dentro de la población
la esté preparada para ajustar ese
bitcoin yo digo que hay mucha gente no
solo yo que en vez de andamos telefonía
gente que ni mi teléfono ni cómo usar un
teléfono entre los economistas la alta
volatilidad del bitcoin es la principal
objeción cuando nosotros estamos pasando
de mercados seguros digamos de
transacciones seguras que se efectúan a
mercados especulativos estamos poniendo
a la economía realmente en una situación
ante compleja el salvador es el primer
país del mundo en dar curso legal a la
cripta moneda dejamos el salvador
hablamos de la celebración del día del
trabajo en eeuu el día de hoy santiago
aunque lamento informarle que no todos
están de celebración hoy en día 2,7
millones de personas en ese país se
reciben las ayudas tradicionales al
empleo pero con la pandemia fueron
creados tres programas adicionales de
alivios federales que beneficiaban a 7
millones este lunes en el día del
trabajo expiran esos programas y el
gobierno de joe biden fue claro en
advertir que no buscaría su extensión
porque la economía ya se está
recuperando y es que la situación
laboral es bien paradójica en ese país
el desempleo llegó al 52 por ciento en
agosto y 84 millones un nivel mucho más
alto que antes de la pandemia cuando era
el 35 por ciento esta cifra contrasta
con un número de vacantes que mes a mes
sigue rompiendo récords y que va en 10,1
millones analistas lo atribuyen a que la
gente no quiere volver al trabajo porque
temen ser contagiados con la nueva
variante del está o porque no encuentran
con quién dejar a sus y jose en casa
pero hay quienes van más allá y culpan
de este fenómeno justamente a estos
subsidios de desempleo que desincentivan
la búsqueda de trabajo daniela hablemos
de ese llamado que hicieron los países
pertenecientes al g20 que urgen por más
ayudas para la vacunación contra el jove
19 en los países más pobres pero es que
ellos las compran todas claro y miren lo
que está pasando santiago este grupo de
los 20 países ricós dijo el lunes que se
necesitan más esfuerzos en ese sentido
italia que ocupa la presidencia del
grupo este año aseguró que la reunión de
líderes que se lleva a cabo entre el
domingo del lunes incluía un acuerdo
para aumentar el apoyo a los países
pobres pero sin embargo de aquello nada
santiago no se habló ni de cifras ni de
compromisos específicos de ayuda las
naciones más ricas han sido criticadas
por supuestamente acumular dosis
mientras que muchos países con bajas
tasas de inoculación aumento de
infecciones luchan por obtener
suministros pasamos ahora rápidamente a
los indicadores eeuu no pero este lunes
por ser festivo pero si lo hicieron las
bolsas europeas que tuvieron un día de
ganancias tras buenos datos económicos
las bolsas latinoamericanas también
iniciaron la semana al alza buenos
aires- se recuperó de tres jornadas a la
baja y para el cierre la cifra del día
sorpréndanos 852 millones de dólares
esto reporta guatemala en inversión
extranjera en 2021 les está yendo muy
bien porque están muy cerca de los 915
millones que se recibieron por este
concepto en 2020 muchas gracias daniela
por este reporte del mundo económico en
la jornada de hoy es todo por el momento
aquí en france24 siga con nosotros
buenas noches